[Music]
after a long search
marvel has finally found her iman valani
will play the role of kamala khan
aka miss marvel for many the casting
will be quite surprising
because valani is still a completely
unknown figure in hollywood in addition
to her
the team behind the scenes has already
been hired including bad boys for life
directors
adil el arby and bilal falah charmeen
obeyed chenoy and mira menon will also
be involved in the directing the former
has won an oscar in the best documentary
category
while manon has made a name for herself
with various projects such as the
walking dead
the punisher and titans the main
character kamala khan like her actress
is not yet well known in the marvel
universe as she did not have her first
comic appearance until 2013 the story
takes place in new jersey where kamala
attends her high school her superpower
is that she can enlarge her limbs at
will which of course is a huge advantage
in combat
key data on the release date does not
exist yet but we expect new information
on the planned disney plus series miss
marvel soon
according to a report in the u.s
magazine deadline anew the lion king
film is in the works to the surprise of
many fans
john favreau will no longer be on board
instead moonlight author barry jenkins
will be the director
more official information about the plot
is not currently known but it is clear
that photo-realistic animals will be
used again
and that jeff nathanson has been hired
again as a screenwriter according to
consistent media reports everything
points to the fact that the new film
will be a mixture of prequel and sequel
partly about the origin story of mufasa
partly about the events after the
original film whether or not this will
be realized together with the renowned
cast around donald glover chihuatella
geofor
john oliver beyonce seth rogen and
company is still in the stars
a potential production start is also not
yet in sight in view of the unclear
situation on the film market
according to deadline the lion king 2
should of course have the highest
priority but on the other hand director
jenkins still has a full schedule and
other projects in the pipeline
especially the post-production will
similar to the first part be a
significant part of the project so we
don't expect a release before mid-2022
the original plan was to bring steven
spielberg's indiana jones 5 to the big
screen last year
however in the end shooting has not even
begun and james mangold has taken over
the director's chair for the long term
after spielberg announced his
resignation in early 2020. many are
still wondering why
after all spielberg has been one of the
most renowned and capable directors in
hollywood for decades in an interview
with den of geek david kepp who also
recently resigned as screenwriter
brought some light into the darkness
especially because the interaction
between spielberg harrison ford
the script and disney turned out to be
extremely difficult in retrospect
nevertheless there was apparently no
scandal behind the scenes
because cap and mangled spoke out on a
professional level whereupon mangled
thought it was the appropriate step to
turn the fifth indiana jones part
completely upside down and start from
scratch
the current start date is still july 28
2022
but fans shouldn't be too sure yet due
to the current situation what do you
think do you give james maygold a chance
or do you think an indiana jones 5
without spielberg is not a real indiana
jones
write us your opinion in the comments
apart from marcus knispel's rather fluff
remake from 2011
conan the barbarian is without a
question one of the classics of the film
world according to deadline
streaming services have been trying to
get the rights for quite some time
first it was amazon's turn but now
netflix has secured the rights the
streaming giant has big plans for the
franchise they are currently looking for
a director and screenwriter for a
potential series but also want to focus
on other projects from the conan
universe in the future an agreement
between netflix and conan properties
international makes this possible it is
now also clear that the amazon series
with game of thrones director miguel
sapochnick which was announced a few
years ago
was of course definitively rejected by
the netflix deal it will be exciting to
see what netflix will turn it into and
we look forward to receiving more
information about the new conan
series the first two seasons of the boys
are now among the most successful amazon
in-house productions as it has now
become known the people in charge have
been working on a spin-off to what is
currently
the hottest superhero series on the
market for quite some time especially
since
genre competitors such as jessica jones
and company have discontinued or put
their projects on ice
the spin-off is supposed to revolve
around the only superhero college in the
usa
and fans can be sure that the series
will once again have a rough and
humorous look similar to the original
craig rosenberg for example who already
wrote the script for the pilot episode
was also signed on as a showrunner he
will be supported by eric kripke
seth rogen evan goldberg and many more
as executive producers while the comic
by garth ennis and derek robertson will
serve as a model not much is known about
the story and the content yet but we
will keep you informed
[Music]
bye